cheshire police suspect a gang from
merseyside is bringing drugs into the
county using local houses to store or
sell class a substances
they don't want to steal out in the
streets because it's easier for us to
catch them the police say the gang uses
a tactic called cuckooing so what they
will do is look for a vulnerable person
whose address they can cuckoo and that's
the term that's what it's known as
similar to the birds stealing the the
other bird's nest
what makes someone vulnerable depends it
could be they have a disability or their
elderly but often it's their drug habit
that's how sarah was targeted we've
changed her name and her voice to
protect her she was using crack cocaine
and heroin it started where the people i
used to get me drugs off i would meet
them but then they would start to come
to my own to drop them off me thinking
they were doing me a favor i thought
they were being kind
then slowly but surely they would turn
up and they would come in and then
they'd come in all hours of the night
and in the morning without warning
if sarah didn't let them in they'd
scream outside her flat until she opened
the door
soon they'd completely taken over her
home and she became a prisoner terrified
she barely moved from the sofa not even
to shower
there's times when i didn't want to be
here it was easier not to be here
and then i was thinking about my family
and
i didn't want to put them through that
and i couldn't tell my family i was
using drugs again um because i didn't
want them to be disappointed
so there was no way out
but eventually she did get out one night
greater manchester police raided her
home looking for the criminals they
found sarah they moved her away from the
area and she's now safe and off drugs
sarah is perhaps a more obvious victim
but the line between the vulnerable and
the gang can become blurred
people who've been cuckooed may end up
committing crimes for those that exploit
them we can't then say well if you've
been involved in criminal activity
you're not a victim that's just not how
it's happening so knowing that
individuals are coerced or forced into
conducting acts that look like to be
criminal acts i think we've got to move
forward both in legislation and in
implementation to recognize them as
victims
sarah lived in fear of the police coming
to her home
in the end it was the thing that saved
her although her escape meant she had to
leave behind family and friends but she
considers herself lucky and worries
about all those who still need to be
rescued becky cottrell sky news